the 2019 Grammy nominations are out but
where was all the love for Taylor Swift
and Nicki Minaj
[Music]
you know I'm all about some toddlers
I've been support in the palace I let
them chemists and Frank but he wanted me
there buddy
so listen here I think the Grammys
actually got a lot of nominations right
great shout out to my queen cardi B but
two women were seriously no I agree now
you mentioned cardi B which makes this
all the worse for it Nicki Minaj who was
completely shut out now the two ladies
have had a history of beefing and while
cardi earned five nominations Nicki
Minaj's snubs are a total surprise so
here's why this is the most shocking her
latest album was perhaps her most
cohesive yet and was released to
favorable reviews now a lot of great
reviews it did now I will say Queen was
not my personal favorite I know there
are a lot of reviews but she's had a ton
of big collabs on the album like eminem
ariana grande and the weekend but it is
said that nicki has never won a grammy
you guys she scored ten Grammy
nominations in the past which this is
not a really big bummer she's not gonna
get that win I also would have loved to
see a Nicki cardi moment at the Grammys
I mean they've sort of squashed that
beef that you mentioned earlier they
seemingly have come together and put
everything behind them so it would have
been nice to see them sort of reunite
and have that photo-op moment right I
agree but you know the Grammys is not
thinking about that only we are so
another leading lady in music who did
not get the Grammy love that I thought
she deserved I know it Taylor Swift
diehard Swift me or not so it said I
would love to say about this so I want
to start with a positive here Taylor did
get a nomination for Best Pop Vocal
album reputation little love but that's
it
nothing in the four major categories
which to me is a huge shock and really
just kind of a disappointment okay so I
agree I'm not a die-hard swifty but I do
think that this was a really big moment
for her reputation was huge yes and
here's the thing Taylor is a Grammy
darling she's won ten Grammys she's had
over 30 nominations reputation was a
massive seller you guys in fact it was
the biggest selling album of 2018
according to Billboard so for it not to
get a Best Album nominate
is especially weird it is really weird
it's a shock
here's a small breakdown by the numbers
so Kendrick Lamar led nominations with
eight Drake scored seven noms and Lady
gaga in country darling Kacey Musgraves
earned five each so a lot of love for a
lot of artists yes I love and I like the
diversity that we're seeing at the the
Grammys this year alright so what did
you guys think of these Grammy
nominations yes let us know on all
things social media I'm at Kourtney
underscore tezo no I'm Katie underscore
Kraus and we'll see you next time